-My next guest
is a Grammy-winning artist
and a judge on the new series
"Clash of the Cover Bands,"
which premieres tomorrow night
at 9:30 p.m. on E!
Here is Meghan Trainor!
[ Cheers and applause ]
No way!
Come on!
Oh, I love you.
Hi, bud.
-Hi!
-Thank you so much
for being on the show.
I appreciate it.
-Oh, thank you for having me.
Every time it's like
my first time ever.
I love you.
-Oh, my God.
You're the greatest.
We have so many things I have
to discuss and talk about.
You know where we have to start,
and this is the headlines --
-Yeah.
This is a real headline
that was trending this week.
Maybe yesterday?
"Meghan Trainor reveals
she and Daryl have two toilets
next to each other
in their bathroom."
That's all anyone could talk
about for the last three days.
-Yeah.
Yeah, my mom's like,
"I wish there was song
attached to this."
[ Laughter ]
But there's not.
I didn't know it was gonna
be such a big deal.
That's why I casually
brought it up on a podcast.
But, yeah, when I --
We moved into this new house,
and, you know, you get up
all throughout the night
with a baby, and you got to pee.
And there's so many moments
where I was like, "Move!"
You know?
I was like, "I have to go."
-Yeah.
-And so when we moved to this
new house, I was like,
"I have an extra toilet.
Can I just pop them
next to each other?"
And the plumber, like, giggled,
and I was like,
"I don't see
why you're laughing.
Like, just do it, get it done."
And they did it, and, like,
it's the best thing I ever did.
-I have to show this
because you --
This is a "Tonight Show"
exclusive.
You brought a photo
of your bathroom.
-Yes.
Oh, yeah.
-This is real.
Look at this.
-All right, so wait.
Now this is --
[ Laughter and applause ]
Meghan.
This is a --
This is a terrible --
This is a terrible idea.
First of all, I don't even --
Should I ask?
Is it rude to ask?
Whose is whose?
[ Laughter ]
-So, mine's -- I -- Mine's
the fancy one on the right.
It, like, warms your butt,
and then the other one
on the left is right under the
air conditioning, so that's his.
[ Laughter ]
-That's so funny.
So, now are you gonna keep this,
or are you going to change it?
-You know how expensive
it would be to change that?
No, this is the best thing
about my house.
It's my favorite
part of the house.
-Now it's legendary.
Now you got it.
You have to do it now.
-Now it's really famous.
I told my contractor,
I was like, "Did you hear?"
He's like,
"My sister told me the news."
I'm like, "You're famous."
-Yeah.
I want to say congrats again.
I know we talked about this.
"A Very Trainor Christmas"
came out.
You have the deluxe version
coming out later this month.
I loved it.
I loved "Holidays"
with Earth, Wind and Fire,
was my jam.
-Yeah!
-That was great.
-Thank you.
-I just -- I --
You know I love the holidays,
so this is, like, massive.
So to come out with --
The deluxe edition has
how many new jams on this?
-Three new jams.
I'm excited about this.
We can call them jams right?
-Gems.
-Oh, gems, of course.
Yes, gems.
They're gems,
but they're also jams.
[ Laughter ]
I think you should come out --
you should come out
with an album of kid songs.
-I think so, too.
That would be a great idea.
Plus, I'm sick of these
old nursery rhymes.
The lyrics are way too dark,
and they're annoying.
So I want to do
a whole new batch of them.
-Dark?
-They're dark.
The lyrics are dark, if you
really think about some of them.
Yeah.
-Yeah.
How is the baby?
-He's perfection.
He's here somewhere,
but he's adorable.
He's 8 months now.
He says, "Mama" and "Dada."
He doesn't know what it means,
but we just accept it.
We're like, "It's me, mama."
So he's great.
-"Mama."
-Yeah.
-You just started him in music
class, which always cute.
How is that going?
-It's great.
That's another thing
that went pretty viral.
But it's -- I got --
I'm like, "I got accepted."
Hilary Duff started this
amazing music class
with a bunch of moms
that she's friends with.
And I showed up, and I was,
like, trying to act really cool,
but I was dying inside
because there was, like,
Miss Mandy Moore
and Ashley Tisdale
and Hilary Duff,
and I'm just like -- [ Gasps ]
"My dreams!"
-Are you --
I know you're a big
"Lizzy McGuire" fan, right?
-Huge.
-Me too.
-Yeah, my alias at hotel names
would be Lizzy McGuire.
But my husband is an even bigger
Mandy Moore fan.
She doesn't know this, though.
But he named his hamster
Mandy Moore
when he was growing up.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh.
He can't admit that to her.
No, no, no, yeah.
But what --
-No.
-So all these --
Mandy Moore's kid and your kid
singing in same music class.
I know they're babies, but
it's got to sound pretty good.
-Singing away.
-I'd buy it.
[ Laughter ]
I'd buy it.
Yeah. I mean, come on.
How cute is that?
-It would be adorable.
-I want to talk about
"Clash of the Cover Bands."
This is tomorrow night on E!
-Yeah!
9:30, Wednesday.
9:30, on E!
I'm excited
because I'm producing this show.
-You're a part of it.
-Yeah.
I'm a major part of this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm so excited that
you did this, because, you know,
I love -- we both love music,
and I do love cover bands.
So when someone
came up with this idea,
I go, "Oh, we got to do this."
We talked about cover bands
when you were on our show
because your family
was in a cover band.
Was it Island Fusion
or something?
-Yes, it was. This is
so embarrassing, but, yes.
I was in a --
-I love the name.
-I was in a band with family,
Island Fusion, and we'd do,
like, pop songs
and soca songs and funk.
It was great.
-Yeah.
And now, doing this,
what was your experience like
being a judge on "Clash of --"
By the way, the winner gets
to come on "The Tonight Show."
-Whoo! And perform.
-And, yeah,
performing on the show.
It's a big deal.
I love --
-And money.
-And they get money.
Yeah, I mean,
this is a game-changer
for a lot of people, yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-But I love --
We can't say who wins
or who our favorites are,
but there were some
knockout performances.
-Yeah.
They were really unbelievable.
I know we had --
I remember we had a Cher
and Celine Dion and --
-Oh, that's right.
-I remember, in the building,
people would come up
to my family and say,
"Oh, my God.
Did you hear that Cher is here?"
Like, they really
fooled everyone
in that building,
because they were so good.
-Yeah.
What do you think is the key
to having a good cover band?
-I think not -- never thinking
that you're better
than the original icon.
And I also loved
a lot of the covers we had
when they would
stay in character.
Like, when we were
interviewing them
and asked them the questions,
they were, like, Bono
or they were Celine Dion.
-Yes!
-And I was like,
"Oh, I love you," yeah.
-Isn't that great?
I remember seeing
a Beatles cover band years ago.
-Yes.
-And they all
just stayed in character.
And they're like, "Hey, John."
"What, Paul?"
He goes, "Right now, there's
$1 tequila shots at the bar."
And he's like --
They were, like,
pitching discounts for booze
at the bar.
I go, "You'd never seen John
and Paul ever do that."
But they loved the Beatles
so much, and they were like --
It was just fun.
And I just --
-Yeah.
-I just thought this experience
was so good.
If you love music,
if you love watching
these awesome battles play out,
it's definitely worth it.
By the way, I will say,
the Elton John is amazing.
-That -- Yeah,
that was one of my favorites.
His outfits are so good.
-Yeah.
And we also, like,
upped the game
once they came to our show,
with wardrobe and whatever
we could do to play it up.
-Oh, yeah.
-I think you're gonna love it,
and you're fantastic on it,
so thank you so much.
It's fun working with you, bud.
-Thanks for thinking of me.
I love you!
[ Laughter ]
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's a peek at
"Clash of the Cover Bands."
Take a look at this.
-That's Bono.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Meghan, break it down for us.
What are the judges looking for?
-So, we're judging you
on vocal impressions.
Do you sound like the icon?
Physical embodiment.
Do you move your body
like the icon?
And, finally,
overall performance.
Did we enjoy it?
And can I just say A-plus, plus.
Y'all are so tight as a band,
and, Sir Bono, I believe you.
You're incredible.
Your vocals
are actually amazing, too.
Like, you're doing
the right thing.
You're doing a great job.
-Thank you.
-Esther, how you feeling?
-I felt very entertained.
You know, Bono, you knocking it,
you rocking it.
But, you know,
U2 is a huge stadium band,
and I would like to see
everybody put it all out there.
You know what I'm saying?
With your movement.
Just take it to the next level.
[ Applause ]
-Thank you so much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We were talking --
I also like the fact that, like,
these bands are also, like,
that guy has seen U2 in concert,
like, over 100 times
or something.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think it was like 78 times
or something beyond that.
It's crazy.
-Studied the band,
every single move,
and when you see him, like --
the guy who's doing Chris Martin
in Coldplay, you're like
"This is just awesome."
It's just so much fun to watch.
-They worship them, and that was
the beautiful part, too.
Because, also, cover bands
don't get enough, like, credit.
They don't.
They work so hard,
and it's their entire life,
it's their passion.
And, like, finally,
you've given them a place
to shine, and I'm so honored
to be part of it.
-Aw, I love you.
Meghan Trainor, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Clash of the Cover Bands"
premieres tomorrow night on E!